we are custodians of fifty and sixty
percent of all of the forest elephants
on the planet we were seeing this spike
in violence
realizing that to keep the Eco guards
alive we needed to give them military
training when I was appointed in 2009
one of the first big issues I had to
deal with was a gold camp just on the
edge of the main cabin national park and
we had definite proof of gun trafficking
drug trafficking human trafficking child
slave labor ivory trafficking Bush me
we lost 25,000 elephants in that time
Patrick McKee beef is on party duty the
same party sit over the zone a la
confianza entre Cameroon udkhulu m7
Treblinka the debond our mayor is on the
cpe given TRADOC whenever the no pack
[ __ ] with the mother the neutrinos
Illinois exact amount
in a country the size of your box with a
small army that's never fought a battle
basically it's a sort of thing that
could destabilize this country but
that's why we bring in people to help
once called regular Captain Rob prints
Lance Corporal Joyce co-pilot corporal
Robert Craig Flanagan second Battalion
the rifles two rifles two rifles two
rifles it's a tragedy that wildlife is
just deteriorating in front of our eyes
to me saving wildlife and keeping these
magnificent beautiful animals around is
really really important if we want to in
the eco gershwin here there'll be a
massive rise in poaching manpower coming
over to Gabon and making the elephants
extinct there's various poaching groups
known to be within Gabon ranging right
up to you more organized groups that do
carry firearms see the leaf on this
burro say took life for all cicadas
barovik get immediately for the birth
don't say Sankar pondrom ah what's all
your coffee it's proving easier to train
the Rangers to become military start
with the passion for their work life and
then add the military layers to the
people that have that disposition I
think because a lot of them come from
quite an ecological academic backgrounds
they have never had formal training in
mission planning and the kind of stuff
that we're delivering so they've been
really enthusiastic and really keen to
learn master by and large they're fairly
well prepared for what they're going up
against but part of what we've been
teaching them is how to risk assess
areas to make the mission safer for
their soldiers and their eco guards who
are going out on patrol Simba Madrid
[ __ ] von Dietrich oh god you take
waffles Mangla mom clapping I wanted to
congratulate a it she jumped
Jim secures a fellowship at the ship a
ship and attract secret weapon rocking
your conference and I want - aqua aqua
nosh portage elephone enough for some
new primary golem on a portage it not be
seen on warranty but this animal second
sister comes your puddle of it per se
I'm the mostest on there's always an
emotive falafel hello mommy
Josie on tell is ignore know how
beautifully they see a beautiful her
yeah through oxygen CI Pradaxa genja
producing a new wave of poaching started
around the same time as the ivory sale
authorised by societies in 2006 more and
more people were going out into the
forest and we're bringing ivory perches
with them definitely the last three
years it's become much more violent
we're averaging about one gun battle a
month and a lot of this over in gold is
going across to Nigeria and making its
way into the Boko harem networks the
ivory trade underpins an illicit economy
so it's not just a wildlife mission it
has another element to it and I think
that's important overall for global
security national security
ready to sample a lead control about
panache new post blue proton and in
telepathy Isola Kuna Yala don't in a
trade important Oh Paco nosh cassava
upper corner reservoir instant crack and
the combat vascular protection is a
protégé a to consume determine that for
vessel avi petitioner for us a
competition of you okay especially cause
we saw fire and smoke flavor to distance
over to the law of God a major cost
around so what I try and do his flank it
and it break up into teams in close
so they punch bullet call enough
information to have know what a welcome
if I how many poachers accordion camp
and they've got free poachers you can
see them hold in ivory so what he's
gonna do now he's leaving his house on
to make sure they don't move he's gone
back to lead the first sort of course
irons back in through so they can flank
him and he gave recesses detention and
prosecution
[Music]
yeah
but
as you can see now the poachers are
trying to assist once you come for the
process get separated they don't get
independent person search and we can't
to that they get all the information
they need and if did commander
determines that they need to make an
arrest and that's what we do
[Music]
they usually contain alpha citrate
efficient portal contain corollary to
this valve angle etcetera difficile yes
it's bizarre on vitamin a mutual
uncontrollable we are in Agra 1 peter
debond power
Valon percent on the number of contain
alpha C panel to Department what the
beef consumed by the parking situation
Zambia immaterial Marion no Patricia no
visa
[Music]
effective conservation principle comedy
Phineas went to graduate education via
immaterial
[Music]
you
[Music]
you